[Música]
y hablamos de la salud con más romero
sala con una muy buena noticia mar buen
día bienvenida al estudio directo
américa el día de hoy la organización
mundial de la salud recomendó ayer la
primera vacuna en la historia contra la
malaria que sabemos sobre este nuevo
múnich ante mar explicarles un poco eso
es para que no digan que sólo hablamos
de malas noticias empezamos con esto que
ya venimos repitiendo desde hace desde
ayer pero pues vamos a profundizar bien
consiste de cuatro dosis las primeras
tres dosis se aplican en los primeros
meses y la última un año después
prácticamente de la última dosis ya son
800.000 menores de edad que han recibido
esta vacuna en un plan piloto que se
hizo después de que superara los
estudios clínicos y se desarrolló en
tres países en malawi en ghana y en
kenia y precisamente desde allí llega un
testimonio de cómo impactó la vacuna en
los centros hospitalarios
lynette advertí
si la vacuna ha tenido un impacto muy
grande porque antes podías tener todas
las camas ocupadas al menos el 70 por
ciento con malaria en cambio ahora
recibimos 3 de cada 16 pacientes con
malaria plate es un porcentaje mínimo a
tu favor y menem al paciente
recordemos las cifras de la malaria raúl
si te parece son 400.000 muertes anuales
provocadas por esta enfermedad de las
cuales el 97 94 por ciento ocurren en el
continente africano y de esas también la
gran mayoría el 63 por ciento afectan a
los menores de 5 años de edad por lo
tanto el impacto a nivel numérico será
gigante pero también a nivel científico
está esta vacuna desarrollada por la
farmacéutica glaxosmithkline
es la primera que se desarrolla contra
un parásito mucho más difíciles de
prever mucho más difíciles de controlar
que una bacteria o un virus y protege
solo contra uno de los cinco patógenos
que provocan la malaria es decir que no
protege contra todos los orígenes de la
enfermedad pero sí contra el que causa
más mortandad tiene una efectividad
moderada entre un 30 y un 50 por ciento
de los casos que se previenen de
enfermedad grave de malaria es decir que
no tiene una efectividad especialmente
elevada pero eso no quita que sea uno de
los principales avances científicos en
contra de esta enfermedad ahora lo que
necesita es inversión en raúl sobre todo
porque sin esta inversión no se va a
poder distribuir a todo el mundo que es
lo que se necesita mejor un porcentaje
de protección que nada más pero ahora
cambiamos información porque suecia
finlandia dinamarca pausa el uso de la
vacuna contra el coi 19 moderna por los
efectos secundarios y si que lo sufrimos
de herta test son muy duros espero que
este efecto particularmente tú no lo
hayas sufrido cómo te sientes del
corazón a veces me da taquicardia pues
yo creo que ya se me está quitando con
el cuello no descartamos que tengas que
ir a una revisión porque de hecho en son
en los hombres menores de 30 años sobre
todo en los que se ha detectado casos de
miocarditis son estudios que se harán
públicos en las próximas semanas así lo
han anunciado los países que han pausado
el uso de modernas pero recordemos que
esto ya había ocurrido
este debate ya lo hemos tenido
especialmente en la inflamación del
corazón ya se recomendó que se siguiera
usando la vacuna pero lo mientras se
publican los nuevos datos podemos ir
revisando los que ya tenemos por ejemplo
datos de estos dos estudios publicados
en eeuu que concluyen que las vacunas de
arene mensajero es decir la de moderna
pero también la de facer provocaron 12,6
casos de miocarditis por millón de
personas que recibieron la vacuna esto
cuando se compara con los riesgos que
entraña tener como 19 es bastante poco
es decir los infectados con kobe 19
desarrollaron en 8 876 casos por millón
de personas también la misma inflamación
de corazón importante destacar son
rangos de edad distintos para cada
estudio es difícil de comparar no es que
sea exacto pero bueno nos sirve para
empezar a orientarnos aún sobre los
riesgos que efectivamente puede tener la
vacuna de moderna y saber que son leves
en comparación con la enfermedad así es
marc y cerramos con una noticia que es
la verdad impacta qué pasa con españa
porque un médico en ese país caracterizó
la enfermedad compramos sexualidad como
enfermedad sí increíble que tengamos que
estar hablando de esto hoy en día pero
bueno no vamos a dejar de hacerlo es una
denuncia que inicialmente recogieron los
medios españoles de una joven de 19 años
que fue al ginecólogo una visita por
desórdenes en su ciclo menstrual algo
que no tiene nada que ver con la
orientación sexual de una persona y que
en cambio terminó con un diagnóstico de
salud donde decía que su enfermedad
actual era la homosexualidad lo están
viendo aquí en la pantalla esa es la
nota que se distribuyó desde la paciente
y también desde el colectivo galactyco
que es quien está acompañando a esta
chica en la denuncia hablamos con ellos
y precisamente pidieron que aumentara la
formación en los profesionales de la
salud y en todos los funcionarios
públicos para poder tratar bien a estas
personas del colectivo de gente que
llegan a las consultas médicas de
escuchemos el mensaje que nos enviaron
nosotros no paramos de exigir una y otra
vez que esto se solucione y queda
diferente los diferentes gobiernos
formen a los profesionales de la sanidad
pública
y que no tengan que sepan cómo tratar la
homosexualidad la bisexualidad la
transexualidad porque hay unas unas
carencias tremendas sin esa formación
pues esto no se seguirá pasando tenemos
nos llegan infinidad de casos
que era un día para recordar que de
hecho la organización mundial de la
salud no desclasificó la homosexualidad
como enfermedad de hasta
1990 apenas 30 años en esas fechas
todavía se consideraba que la
homosexualidad era un desorden el
psiquiátrico es decir que todas las
personas gays lesbianas eran personas
enfermas desde entonces hemos mejorado
mucho pero no basta decir que hasta día
al día de hoy todavía hay estigma
todavía hay una discriminación que esa
es la principal barrera para las
personas de disidentes de identidad de
género y de orientación sexual para
acceder a la salud precisamente porque
hay consultas médicas como la de este
ginecólogo que no son espacios seguros
para tratar la salud de las personas el
más grave mar que un médico le diga a
uno que la enfermedad es que sea
homosexual o bisexual o lo que sea su
discriminación no tiene nada que ver con
tu enfermedad 100% mar muchísimas
gracias por toda la información de salud
nos vemos mañana viernes con más temas
interesantes que a todos nos concierne
porque es nuestra salud